Let's will about the Joe Rogan experience.
I don't know if he does it as much or as often as I do,
but I do cause I do the clubs.
I have a philosophy about what's required to develop great standup that you have
to do a lot of sets,
you have to do a lot of numbers,
a lot of different places,
different environments and I found that out the hard way through my best
performances in my less good performances.
Like what was missing and what did I do
game you like racy I think is there sort of an interesting debate a,
you know,
I don't know if it's in standup world at large but it's only saying I've thought
about a lot is like that as soon as I was able to have an audience that would
come and see me,
I was like I'm out.
Thank you God,
you know that I'm not putting myself through that shit again.
Those Dan hope feels the same way.
By the way.
He's one of the best and he's amazing.
He's absolutely fantastic.
I completely agree.
And like,
cause I,
I fought like,
cause what I feel like is that the comedy club environment warps your material
because you've got a appeal to them.
And I think you ain't the fucking arbiters of truth.
You've drunk and crazy too.
Am Mutha fuckers like so I get a lot.
I perform.
I'll,
what I'll do is I am,
what I'm doing to say at the moment is I'll book the UCB like a or like places a
hundred,
200 or go Largo or put on events and I'm doing events while,
I mean La Cause I think,
oh these people come and they love me and they bring me beads and then here's
some vegan cookies and are you got to come to the comedy store man and go on
after Joey Diaz.
[inaudible]
cause I feel like I like a nurturing environment.
It got in there.
I mean cause I've done those fucking clubs and like,
you know,
uneven comedy store and late at night comedy store in La,
as well as London.
And I felt like,
oh Jesus,
thank God.
And after,
so like I'm interested to you.
That's part of that.
What I think some people could reductively refer to his machismo in you like
that you go,
no,
I'm going in now.
It is.
It's that guy that mounted you and went for the arm bar new escaped.
Right.
It's worth it because it was hard.
You like,
you realize if a child got on top of you and went for an arm bar,
new escape,
you'd feel nothing.
So when you're at Largo,
you're performing for children.
Yeah,
you're doing child stand up.
It's like
wrestling with a hundred pound women who just started yesterday.
You like the make a wish foundation.
Go Russell.
Then tell us your stories.
[inaudible] wonderful.
We brought him flowers.
Thank you.
Thank you children.
But,
but like look,
the counter argument to that is that therefore I am in an environment that is
sympathetic and he is my audience and I'm not biasing I you what?
You know,
the idea of overcoming a greater obstacle.
I completely appreciate what you're saying,
but say you believe in the pure EIF stand up as being some real expression of
yourself as in the Arrow hitting the bullseye.
I feel like I have a vision of what I'm trying to achieve and increasingly is
becoming about I want my stand up,
I want to hang on.
You know,
like as I've always done stories where I feel embarrassed and humiliated,
but I want to hang off it ruminations on what are believed to be the nature of
truth.
And I want people to come out of those things feeling loved,
validated,
accepted,
and that they're good enough and that they can explore themselves.
You know?
That's more of a one man show in a sense.
It's that,
but I don't want to like sacrifice the laughs,
you know?
I mean,
I love the loss,
the loss,
what is where we're at,
you know,
that's,
you don't have to sacrifice in a one man show.
I mean,
you can certainly do a one man show that it'd be really funny,
but say you start going into,
yeah,
that's what I'm doing and I'm sort of,
I'm trying to build things like around 12 steps and trying to like doing things
that people have some takeaway value from now.
Like,
you know like trying to develop that after Joey Diaz in the store.
It's going to be some resistance.
You are aware of Hannah Gadsby and the controversy of this?
I haven't seen it.
Yeah.
Not necessarily.
I'm going to see it,
but because what the end of comedy and all that kind of thing,
it's silly.
It's no end of comedy.
But she what she's doing people like,
and there's nothing,
I don't know what you call it,
whatever you want.
Sometimes it's funny,
I mean maybe it's standup comedy.
Some of my mates version,
they told me towards the end it black of become a sort of quite aggressive
towards you and it came like a tedtalk almost.
I guess.
Apparently I'm interested in or you know,
that's,
you know,
yeah,
there's enough room for everyone to exert,
to do whatever they're doing but at like see at the beginning of my guys call it
Korea,
like I used to not prepare at all.
I was still drinking and using.
I'd got up on stage,
I chop shit up.
I'd get into confrontation.
When I say truck shop,
I'd take up animals,
shit,
part animal parts.
I'd got from Brookshire's like like a skull.
We've all meat and stuff and send you on it,
chop it up for a news release.
Locusts get into confrontations like so yeah,
exactly.
The reaction you're having,
his direction they were having,
that's as soon as the front row.
I had like a fight.
I've got scars on my body from bad standup gigs from a time where I've got into
a confrontation.
Like I was making a point about pedophilia saying,
oh,
we're all one cultural mind.
So when a particular Peter File is transgressed against a child,
we're all responsible.
People are like,
what the fuck?
They're like,
I've got the shit kicked out.
Well that time,
you know,
I've still got the scar on my leg that happened at Edinburgh in Scotland.
People didn't take it well like so,
but what I was trying to do was like create,
I didn't have the skills,
the chops,
the experience than jokes.
So is so under equipped,
but like what I was trying to do was create environments that felt,
you know,
I'm much better at doing that now.
I can create at kind of an uncertainty in a room or kind of a sense of chaos and
what's happening and then bring it back.
I hope to a humorous conclusion where people feel safe and amused and all of
that kind of stuff.
Now I think it's you like,
cause I did try and do that in comedy clubs and yeah it was compensation.
It's not what people want.
So don't you think that by prepping your stand up in those environments that it
biases you towards a type of standup comedy that is limited?
No,
because you can do that other stuff too.
You can always perform to your crowd and you could always expand on things to
your crowd.
But to really put it together without any fluff,
without any nonsense,
without being self indulgent,
with respecting the attention span of the audience that may or may not even be
there to see you most likely is not.
If you go to a comedy club and there's a large,
you know,
if you go to the comedy store any night of the week,
there's 15 plus people on the marquee or on the list.
And the show starts at 8:00 PM or 9:00 PM depending on the night and it goes to
two o'clock in the morning and you know,
you catch waves in there and there's different types of comedy and in that
you're going to deal with sometimes tired audiences,
sometimes enthusiastic people.
It's all different.
It varies widely.
And I think that um,
in doing that you cut all the nonsense out of your act and you develop an
economy of words.
You understand how to captivate people's attention and keep them engaged and to
respect their time,
respect their point of view,
respect that these people have an attention span,
they want to be engaged in,
in the best possible way that you can do it.
And sometimes you develop that through these really difficult sets or you know,
distracted people and drunks and all that stuff.
You can develop that,
those qualities.
You're always going to have your crowd and what your crowd,
I mean if you have this,
this vision of how you want to put things together,
you could put that kind of thing together at a comedy club.
You're doing it in these 15 minute chunks,
you just have to figure out a way to grab them and make them really interested
in what you have to say.
You're right.
Because there's obviously in like the comedy store between now as you've just
described,
there's a contract,
we're here not gaining at cu.
We're to love every 15 seconds.
I'm like,
you know comics like,
you know,
like Robin Williams or Chappelle's the,
the all time greats.
They went,
they go in and accept those conditions and I,
you know,
you've seen stuff I'm sure like Robin Williams,
he's just like walking around in the crowd in that very room and do is like,
he's like,
he's doing the thing I'm talking about and he's doing it there.
You know?
That's when you think,
yeah.
If I suppose I do get that,
that your road testing it to you,
each durability to an incredible degree if you can pull it off there.
Yeah.
Well,
think about every time you're saying something when you're,
you have a subject like say if you want to,
do you want to talk about the mentors that you have in life?
There's,
it's an open ended approach.
You have no idea what the correct way to say something is.
You try it,
you,
you write it out,
you say,
this seems feasible.
Let me try it this way.
And oftentimes people never correct it or they never,
they never adjusted,
they never go back and improve it.
They just say it in a certain way and figure out how to do it.
When you're doing an in front of a crowd,
you're developing these things while also feeling the way people reacting to
them and feeling their attention span and it makes you with proper reflection
and truly objective listening to your material.
It makes you change and shift and adjust things and hopefully in a positive way.
And the more you do it,
the more you get a sense of,
maybe this is clunky here and maybe I figured out a better way to say it and
I agree.
But the counterargument could be the,
it could buy us you to a sort of a lowest common denominator area.
Say where that bit where you talk about the sun and you know it's,
you know,
you need it,
he's trying to kill you.
It gives you cancer,
you know,
like something like what was the journey of that bear stand up.
Is this like for me it's like,
oh I think of before I try and make sure there's a tag so I know where I'm going
when I'm out there.
And then it's as comparable process do yours,
you're trying your best to get rid of fluff or wherever.
So can you recall like why it's like,
you know,
are you night after night go in in with new bits of material,
packaged within fee things that you are a little more confident?
I put that bit on a special,
I can do it better now.
Better way to do it.
And that's part of the problem with doing bits.
So like sometimes you released them on a special,
you have a better version of it now.
But my point of that was to a prospective enhancer to let people know that bit
was about like understanding what's happening here.
You are literally floating in infinity and it's almost never discussed.
You're hurling through forever.
There's a fireball on the sky,
it's a million times bigger than earth.
If you stare at it,
you'll go blind.
It's trying to give you cancer and if it's not there,
you get sad.
You live in a dream like this is madness.
You're life is madness and beautiful.
Yeah it is.
But I wanted,
there's something about that particular way of IX seat cause I figured out a way
to express it short in short doses,
in short bursts,
if you know,
if you stared at would go blind and he's trying to give you cancer and if it's
not there,
you get sad.
So in that short bursts like myths,
you know like wow.
Yeah,
that is all those things are true.
Like this is crazy.
There really is a fireball floating in the sky and we're just used to it.
We live because of a floating million times bigger than the earth.
Fireball and I,
when you say,
if you could say something like that and make someone laugh,
you can actually change the way they look at things.
You can actually affect at least the way they look at things.
If you just say something,
sometimes it's profound.
Sometimes it registers,
but if you could say something and it forces someone to laugh,
even if they disagree with you,
if they're laughing like,
I don't even fucking agree with this,
but holy shit,
this is funny.
You put that thought deep into someone's head and you allow them to think about
your thought process and how your creative process and what you're doing to sort
of bring these things out.
Yes.
I like the way you just described the architecture of that.
You've got to basically have,
these are some facts about the sun irrefutable.
Now here is how that affects the way we look at the world and exposes to us that
we're just ignorant.
We're not awake to reality.
We can't hold reality in our minds because it's too vast to handle.
I like it and I agree with you that let you know that way of laughter comes
access to kind of truths.
And I've heard some therapists in fact say that,
uh,
like the laughter is to shame what grief is to sadness.
That laughter is helping to expel shame and to process Shane.
That is something very important about people coming together and laughing
together.
Uh,
I,
I like to exist comedically in worldwide.
I start from a deeply personal perspective and an admissions and
acknowledgements of humiliation and shame and vulnerability and travels out to
the universe or,
and hopefully archetype all that you can sort of travel between those points.
The comedian,
nothing.
We both admire Bill Hicks.
Well I think he's fascinating.
He's got to let you know,
like if you've loved Bill Hicks for a long while,
then you discover,
man,
that guy works material a lot.
You know,
like you go,
I watched this interview with him on the Australian TV.
He's doing like a bit that I've seen him do,
you know,
in multiple incarnations.
But I have also seen him do interviews,
ways spontaneously talking about gigs,
terrible gigs that have gone badly.
And he is hilarious.
But it's very interesting to me,
and perhaps it's because of that background and that practice of doing clubs
that Hicks is very much a comedian that's,
no,
I'm drilling this fucking thing and I'm staying with it.
He was a writer.
I mean,
he did ad Lib and he did.
He was capable of going on these rants,
spontaneous rounds.
But he was a writer.
He wrote these things out,
and he was aiming to have an impact with his commentary.
I mean,
that was what was was he was doing.
It was not just trying to make you laugh,
he was aiming to enhance your,
your perspective on whatever he was talking about.
Yeah.
And as a,
it seems very disciplined as a practitioner of it.
Yeah.
[inaudible].